Hello friends, we have seen Akshay animals being
camouflaged like Camel
Leon and Joe, but have you ever
heard of any plant that
camouflages itself? Yes, today I will tell you
about such a unique hidden prey.  The
name of the plant is Vacuolar.
It is
found in regions like Chile and Argentina. It is basically a
climber and can grow up to 20 m long.
This plant becomes similar in color and shape to the leaves around it, due to which it has its own unique shape.  Is it
possible to do moclage easily in the environment and if the child is late from his father, then
this strange
thing happened, for such information, stay
connected with us and subscribe to the live show.